buenos días el presidente pedro casi o
había prometido a los peruanos un
gabinete de ancha base para buscar la
gobernabilidad pero hizo todo lo
contrario nombró al confrontacional
aníbal torres como nuevo primer ministro
que decide muchos este nuevo gabinete
está estructurado para confrontar al
parlamento desde ya muchos rechazan algo
algo de este equipo de gobierno porque
consideran que trae más de lo mismo y no
solamente eso señalan que es
completamente extraño que en plena
campaña de vacunación contra el coi 19
el presidente castillo haya cambiado al
ministro de salud a fernando ceballos
para poner en su lugar a un aliado de
vladimir cerrón su socio político quien
gana en más poder porque se ha nombrado
a tres ministros que están relacionados
con él francisco también 30 días el
nuevo primer ministro hablamos de aníbal
torres se debe presentarse ante el
congreso de perú obtendrá entonces el
voto de confianza y se acabará esta
crisis política que parece que nunca
deja de decir de existir en perú
bueno va a ser complicado que el primer
ministro aníbal torres tenga el voto de
confianza muchos congresistas lo
consideran autoritario y no solamente
eso no están de acuerdo con los
integrantes de este nuevo gabinete de
gobierno pero lo más complicado es que
cada día son más los que le piden al
presidente pedro castillo que renuncie
desde ya el parlamento está preparando
dos caminos para conseguir que pedro
castillo salga del poder
uno es la vacancia la moción de vacancia
para la cual se requieren 87 votos la
otra vía es una acusación constitucional
que están preparando contra el
mandatario luego de que éste haya
mencionado la necesidad de otorgar mar a
bolivia esto es considerado como
traición a la patria pues bien la crisis
política en perú lamentablemente tiene
para rato